[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream number 22 section 3
the Q & A we are gonna get to your Q's
with our A's that's what we do here oh
boy that sounds wrong - that does sound
right ok well let's do you like to take
it back so we want to thank Eric for for
having the the first of what we hope are
many conversations that we have of
course we've been having conversations
like this with him privately for decades
but we need these conversations to
become more public now I thinking we
should start a club we can be the first
members the first against the wall' Club
what do you think mmm I don't like it I
kind of do like it ok maybe I'm the only
member of the first against of all yes I
guess I also before we start in on the
questions from your super chat in the
first live stream and the second and
then we'll get to the third and we'll do
as many as we can in an hour I also
wanted to thank our moderator who is
anonymous but is a good friend and doing
just a bang-up job and we we appreciate
you greatly and we don't we don't see
the chats really see the super check
questions but we know from the
assessment that the moderator gives us
after every time that you're fighting
the good fight thank you indeed thanks
so much
ok so without further ado we wanted
there was one question there have been
questions every time that we've missed
that have been good but there was one in
particular that we just didn't even see
last time it came in at the end of the
super chat that was excellent I wanted
to start with it and it turns out that
the same person has rewritten the
question this time so that gives me even
more reason to prioritize this Morrigan
rights if the left wants to win they
need to care about the civil rights of
the right
I have no public voice no news no social
media gives me a platform the left will
have no mercy for me or anyone who
thinks like I do if they win convince me
otherwise
yeah the this is really question of how
you parse things
that thing out there that is putting
people against the wall forcing them to
bend the knee all of the things that it
is doing it's not the left those people
may think they're the left but this is
the most intolerant movement I have seen
in my lifetime so the thing to
understand is that essentially left and
right have become unimportant at the
moment because what we are looking at is
a challenge to the things that unite
left and right now I got a challenge
from Dave Rubin yesterday in which he
basically said that what we are all
seeing is a demonstration that the
Conservatives had it right all along and
that us liberals have to admit it this
is not the case this country was founded
by radicals and liberals who have
upgraded the system again and again and
conservatives provide a necessary
tension the Liberals left to their own
devices would muck the thing up with a
overly great enthusiasm for change and
for attempts to fix things and an
insufficient appreciation for unintended
consequences so the tension between the
instinct to improve things and the
desire to preserve that which functions
is the magic that makes America work so
that is to say if you are on the right
you are united with those on the Left
who are making sense no matter how few
of us there may be and I don't think
it's as few as as one might be led to
believe I think a lot of us have been
portrayed is on the right in order that
the left doesn't have to deal with us
for the same reason they don't want
science empowered they don't want cogent
people on the Left saying hey wait a
minute this isn't making sense to me get
off your knees they don't want that so
anyway we're in this together the
Patriots the people who understand the
values that make the West so powerful
and that make it the envy of the rest of
the world those things are in jeopardy
and we must all defend them so there's
no left to right it's not that you need
your rights protected as somebody on the
right if you're an honorable person
then you're on board with the rest of us
we've got to protect all of our rights
oh well I'm gonna push back on that a
little bit because I think that sounds
wonderful but it sounds a little bit
like fantasy space because we are we do
have different you know we share values
we share values across almost the entire
left and almost the entire right but we
do as you have most aptly of anyone I've
ever heard described what you know the
differences are that we share values and
we and we disagree too on the extent to
which we have already achieved those
values in society and on the kinds of
solutions that we that we seek to
resolve the remaining inequalities and
problems in society so that you know
there are real differences and we do
speak in terms of left and right but I
certainly agree with you that the
leftists so-called just like the alt
rightists so-called our extremists who
really bear no resemblance to in the
case of the leftist a liberal and
progressive understanding of what it is
that we should be doing in the world
just as the old rightists don't have any
resemblance to what good faith
conservatives believe but I will say to
to the writers question Zach if you
would put up this screen I'm just going
to show a screenshot of a tweet I wrote
a couple days ago in a long tweet thread
totalitarianism always flies in on the
wings of beautiful ideals it lands
gently flatters you and charms you makes
you feel smart for recognizing how
beautiful it is
do not be fooled it is dangerous those
ideals they are not what they seem and
it got a lot of attention but someone
says to me in response you are
definitely definitely not on the Left
and this person is trying to claim the
mantle of being on the left and
basically saying that I by speaking to
the current moment as a totalitarian one
cannot possibly be on the left and that
strikes me as simultaneously a
horrifying misunderstanding of what it
would be to seek to live in a liberal
society and also take it down please
sack also sorry I lost my train of
thought there is an embarrassing
admission on their part they've revealed
their
understanding of what the left is I do
want to push back on your push back
though I'm not saying there's no
difference between left and right
obviously there is and the reason I
would say I'm a radical is that I
believe we need change now that we are
in trouble in our current trajectory
we'll be fatal if we don't have it which
puts me on the left but I also have said
I want to live in a civilization that is
so fair and so functional that I can
afford to be a conservative we should
all want to live in that society and
people who are who feel that they are
always going to be in favor of change
are basically telling you that they're
not really interested in building
something wonderful so we can safely
ignore them my point is just look we are
facing a very powerful enemy and it is
threatening the values that we share
so of course we're on the same team
right we're we're allies by virtue of
the fact that there's no disagreement
amongst the good people about the values
that are now under threat so anyway yes
we can let's let's repeal this threat
and get to a place where we can again
fight over whether or not we need to
make progress or preserve things as they
are that'll be wonderful if we get to
that point
next question there's a good argument to
ignore race and genetics a consequence
seems to be persistent historical
anti-semitism Jewish success in many
fields includes a quarter of Nobel
laureates and that seems to be either a
general cognitive advantage or the
Jewish conspiracy it's what I think I
think Eric and particular was talking
about this and in the last live stream a
little bit I think he addressed some of
this well you know that here's the
problem is that the answer to this one
is uncomfortable right is there
something cognitively special about Jews
or isn't there and I think the answer is
there is but I don't think it's genetic
it's not certainly not inherently
genetic what I would say is there is
something about the level of oppression
and enduring it in other words there's
something very anti fragile about Jewish
thinking as a result of all of the
challenges that you have faced and the
you know I know from experience as a
cultural geo not a religious Jew I know
that there is something
in the culture about holding each
other's feet to the fire right it was
dinner table conversation it was you
know Passover Seder as it was it was
baked into what it meant to be Jewish so
much so that it was baked in it was
actually big and you know the thing is
when you do that when every interaction
involves what I think people have
actually frankly seen in our podcast
hear us pushing back on each other and
it not being personal and you know the
affection being a constant and not
washing back and forth in the ebb and
flow of belief right that culture works
to make you insightful and what I've
said and it is sorry but it has me on my
observation growing up in a non-jewish
family but with my mother's dearest
friend and business partner was Jewish
and so we spent a lot of time with her
and I came to think of her almost as a
as a secondary mom and I had you know
many Jewish friends whose homes I went
to and spent time at and then obviously
having spent a lot of time with your
natal family at this point that the the
consistent thing between all of these
all of these families all of these
Jewish homes is the simultaneous loan
respect and willingness to disagree and
push back and it is that thing and it's
exactly the opposite of the concept of a
safe space and you know these super
fragile little beings that can't ever
have disagreements the opposite of
helicopter parenting it's the opposite
of so much of what we've been taught to
value and that we see being ascendant in
modern culture and so you know why why
is that correlated with success in a
world in which not just collaboration
but yes also competition is going to be
important well it's it is effectively an
informal scientific method you end up
testing your ideas because anytime you
say anything that's wrong you know that
people at the table are gonna figure out
why it's wrong or try to help you figure
out why it's wrong it just will happen
yep and I want to push back slightly on
the idea that you didn't grow up and you
home because I think no I mean the point
look but I know it's a head scratcher
yeah but it's not really because look I
suspect my mother and my brother are
watching right now they're like what
what are you talking right well here
this is what I'm talking about the magic
of human beings is that they are a
generalist platform physically we are a
generalist creature with a mind that is
not highly pre-programmed it's not to
say it's a blank slate it isn't but it's
the blank a slate that has ever existed
in nature right that blanks that blank
ish slate allows a software program to
be loaded onto the mind and the fact is
your home wasn't Jewish in the sense
that either of your parents were Jewish
but you were you went to school with
lots of Jews by virtue of where you
lived in the world
your mom's best friend was Jewish your
dad's work environment and computer
science would have been filled with many
Jews and the point is look it's not that
every aspect of Jewishness is fantastic
but the basis never had a seder at home
but that doesn't mean that Jewish
culture wasn't omnipresent in our lives
right and you know we live like this
elsewhere right like we'd take you know
tomatoes to be part of Italian cuisine
they're not they are not originally part
of Italian cuisine but they've been they
can't be they come from a totally
different continent right so the point
is you know should we you know should an
Italian restaurant be limited to nothing
with tomatoes no of course not the point
is tomatoes have been naturalized into
Italian cuisine the way a Jewish
perspective where I would argue
affection and affinity are orthogonal
from agreement that is to say we can
disagree and it has nothing to do about
whether we love each other and so anyway
I think you had a lot of that in your
life I think it's you know herbs and
flows through judeo-christian culture
and the most important thing is to
whatever extent it's good I'm not saying
it's singular there are other cultures
that will have every one of those
aspects somewhere it's democratizing
right yeah because it's culture and not
dreams it can be passed on it can be
utilized by anybody just like the
scientific method and so the
democratization of the tools that work
is the key
and to the extent that Jews have
demonstrated that it is possible to be a
small and often despised group of people
and still thrive
maybe Jews know something about how to
do it so anyway I know that's complex
and weird but I do think that's what
that Ruth flies I think we should come
back to this frequently actually okay
next question where does this go if
social media and everyone in the public
eye continues to kneel and effectively
show their jugular to the Bob how can
the silent majority get the truth out to
those who are on the fence or who truly
don't understand the issues so these
again these are questions from the first
live stream you know before we were on
with with Eric unfortunately people want
something they often want something from
us I know I get approached frequently by
people navigating these kinds of issues
in their in their own life you know do I
stand up I'm in jeopardy how do I do it
how do I make it safe there's no good
answer and as I think we were pretty
clear earlier today there's nothing that
makes this moment safe in fact it could
hardly be more perilous I know of no
feature of the environment but that
stands between what we are currently
seeing and a flat-out Maoist revolution
that overturns everything right it could
happen will it happen
I don't know but it could and if it did
what would that mean about what your
fate would be for standing up I have no
idea but what I can say is there's no
safety in cow towing to the mob or at
least no safety that you'd want it it's
a it's not a viable position for an
intelligent person you will hate
yourself for doing it and you will be
reviled by history so I think the answer
do you do I mean I this is we are now in
a different position than we would have
been if this were happening four years
ago and we were unknown you know beloved
at our college but unknown to the rest
of the world biologists and you know we
are doing what we know how to do but
we're but it's still it's still too
little and we're trying to figure out
what else to do and you know the idea
that you know Eric's going to get the
band back
together its use his framing on social
media and and you know bring together a
bigger conversation is is critical but
what about people who don't have any
kind of platform who are you know
finding themselves in zoom meetings
right now where everyone begins by
announcing their pronouns and and
explaining how their inner racist is
finally clear to them and they're
apologetic for years to come and you
know incidentally to Eric's point that
he made in the last livestream about it
seeming to be often the people with the
least actual intimate knowledge you know
in terms of friendship and family and
experience of other of people who look
different who are doing this most this
is actually a point that I have as you
as you know that I have made many times
that I observed anecdotally I wouldn't
even actually know how to begin to do
the stats on it but I sort of began to
try to what we saw at Evergreen was that
the people who were most loud and most
most vociferous about their whiteness
and their racism were exactly the people
who I know just because I know who they
are to have the least experience of the
world to have traveled the least to have
the most sort of the most limited
homogeneous experience of the world and
I don't know if they were actually
wondering if they're racist or if they
were just going wow I just don't know
but the fact is that those of us who
actually have traveled have lived have
been in places where we aren't you know
we aren't the dominant phenotype even
though our skin color always carries
privilege no matter where we go on this
planet we can we can look into our
hearts and say you actually know not
racist so stop making me pretend that I
am something that I'm not because I know
what happens if you start making me lie
so the people who can't look into
themselves and say well am i I'm not
sure who can't come back with a
resounding I'm sure or not are most
likely to be the ones who are carrying
the flags and
and you know basically making the
loudest of themselves in the streets and
trying to force the others to do the
same okay so here's my advice then good
the the fact is if you do what they want
you to do if you get on your knees and
you beg forgiveness and you swear that
they're right about what their claims
are they will not respect you they will
use you and then they will throw you
away at the end your fate is not going
to be an honorable one you will either
end up a servant or in a ditch that
means the best thing to do is to make
your peace with the fact that there is
no safety to be had and then make your
point about why it is that you are not
compelled about this now if there's
honor on the other side it will
recognize that the strength to say
what's true and to stand up to this even
though they don't like it is the sign of
somebody with integrity somebody with
depth of character and it will not
protect you it may put you on their
radar but what it means is that in the
end you will be able to look at yourself
in the mirror and I don't know I don't
know how you're gonna do it frankly as
I've said before for me it's automatic
right it doesn't really matter what the
consequence is the consequence
personally to me of pretending I agree
with this stuff would be so catastrophic
that there's just it's easy there's just
no choice to make you literally wouldn't
be able to sleep yeah I mean it's not
even that it's like I cannot get to the
point of saying okay what would I even
say right if in that hallway I don't
know what the other speech would have
sounded like I literally cannot imagine
formulating those words so if that's not
where you are if that is where you are
then this is easy and great well it's
it's easy but your livelihood might be
at risk oh it's not safe but if the
choice part is easy cuz it's not a
choice it's not a choice yeah it's just
not a choice but if that's not where you
are and it's not where most people are
unless let me just so I mean
two of our dearest friends a couple of
months before Evergreen blew up one of
whom is at Evergreen and one of whom is
is my oldest friend in the world someone
who we then went to high school with she
was up visiting us i sat at lunch with
him faculty member at Evergreen and her
eye
woman I've known since we were both in
fifth grade I think and they were saying
to me this would have been I don't know
March of 2017 something like this we
know that what Brett is doing is
necessary and true and honorable but
it's not going to end well it doesn't
know does he know that and neither of
them were saying stop
none of them would neither of them would
ever but they were so worried and it
struck me at the time that that was sort
of where I was too you know I was
obviously I was I was behind the scenes
you know with your emails and such but
and you know and living a lot of it more
deeply than than they were but they
almost I think they were almost asking
me like given that he must know the
danger does he understand the risks and
at the same time these two people who
both know you pretty darn well we're
saying we understand it's not a choice
yeah it was it's not choice it's not a
choice yeah and you know I think this
also has something to do with with
Jewish culture especially growing up
when we did which you know and she
aren't my oldest friend our good friend
from only time I get was also Jewish
she's also doing and I'm sure he his
father is his Japanese japanese-american
his father was in the camps the the
Japanese internment camps so both of
these people have familial history
oh you'll experience deep deep
oppression but there's something about
you know we were we were both born in
1969 so that seemed during our
childhoods at least to me like a very
long distance from
world war ii world war ii felt like deep
history but of course it wasn't right it
was recent and anyway the discussions
amongst kids the discussions at the
dinner table all those things were kind
of preparation for well what if this
happens again right it can happen again
it can always happen and i think that
there's just there's a circuit people
say you don't know you don't know what
we would have done you know in nazi
germany you don't know and i feel like i
know right and you know you could
swallow them what would have happened
well would have taken a shot at as many
nazis as i could and i probably would
have died in the process period it would
not have ended up in the camp right now
there's a way in which that's unfair
because germans at the time german jews
didn't have the experience of knowing
where it was going
but having grown up at a time when i did
have the benefit of seeing what happened
in those circumstances it's just not
even a question now there are things
that give one pause it always looks
different
of course right like so you know you get
any you history doesn't repeat itself
you know but it rhymes right so you know
how close does it have to be for you to
recognize that it's the same thing
that's a it's the same enough thing this
is so weird to talk about because it's
so personal but i feel like it doesn't
matter okay you know and i feel like it
doesn't matter because it has to lie it
has to lie that ideology yeah yeah it
has to lie and if it has to lie then all
you have to do is be resistant to being
able to be forced into a line and you're
certainly safe from becoming part of it
you're not safe but you say from
becoming part of it and so no i feel
pretty much completely secure that such
a thing could not arise and trick me
right it's not to say i can't be fooled
by anything but if it's one of these
power grabs that forces you into an
ideology that isn't right in order to do
its bidding because it's obvious what
it's doing so once and some of it is you
know some of some of the easier advice
to give is look at what look at how
cults function yeah and if
if it yells at you when you start
questioning it it run away if you aren't
allowed to assess how it came to its
conclusions or disagree with any of its
conclusions right away yeah James
Lindsay has been lazy yeah and his
poison is his strongest point in this
realm is at the point that it distances
you from your family you know what it's
up to if it doesn't want you talking to
your family and friends there's a reason
and it's because it cannot withstand
pushback yeah it cannot withstand
scrutiny yeah
so all I can say is I think you'll feel
better the sooner you make your peace
with the danger and the sooner you
become clear about what you believe in
why and then you know it's a very
interesting story to be on the right
side of so good luck
oK we've got a couple of comments before
more question so many questions here
really comes through three of them this
is a comment continuous equivocation
tactic choosing language open to a
continue of interpretation that the
issuer may judge in context so
thankfully vary their claimed as desired
interpretation it's often used to stock
extremes over time that sounds exactly
right so yes arguing or he or she is
arguing that that is the Adam known and
name for this thing the the continuous
version at the mountain Bailey yeah the
continuous version of the mountain bei
continuous equivocation tactic I wish it
was sexier but yeah a continuous
equipment continuous equivocation tactic
okay thank you yeah maybe if you wink at
the end of it you wake that's not a sexy
to support as long as I am able thank
you and I was gonna buy Mortal Kombat 11
but you all deserve it more keep up the
good work both of you thank you
appreciate that you could also invest in
some immortal technique I had a brief
encounter with some of immortal
techniques music and I'm hoping he has
stood strong and is on the right side of
this fight
no you don't do okay I'm seeing many
including the Republican governor of
Vermont where I live claiming that it's
no longer okay to be not racist and that
we almost become equitable and
anti-racist what do people mean by
anti-racist you might also ask Oh to
people being by equitable because until
you've gone down this rabbit hole you
think it means you think equity is the
same thing as equality and it's not
equality is something we can and all
should get behind equality under the law
equality of opportunity insofar as it is
possible but equity is a way of changing
changing outcomes after all of the
opportunity has already ended such that
some people are lifted up in a very
unequal way so there's that that there
is a lot in the concept of equity that
legitimately can be pushed back against
I'd be interested to hear good faith
defense of the concept of equity but it
is it is one of these things that's been
slid in as if it's equivalent to
equality and it's not and so then the
other question is about anti-racist I
was how is it not being racist distinct
from being anti-racist so the problem
with all of these things is that they
are they are Trojan horse concepts and
obviously any reasonable person should
be anti-racist until people define that
term in such a way that you can't
possibly be it because it is the enemy
of anti racism all right these things
are all going to be turned on their head
and you know it's the same thing with
equity equity used to mean something
very close to equality and then it was
transmuted into something that is
actually so if you know if equality of
opportunity is the desired goal then
equity is like the communist version or
was like the communist version which has
a quality of outcome and now equity has
been transmuted into something even far
beyond what communism communism doesn't
work but it's at least coherent the
claim is coherent what it's a coherent
ideology yeah it's a coherent ideology
that won't work for reasons that
actually come down to group selection
and game theory but never mind we can
talk about that another
but the equity movement now is not even
communist it's beyond communist because
what it is really advocating for is a
state and you can you know you could
hear it in the the thing that Eric read
from was it Caltech or you can hear it
in what was being said to us at
Evergreen that equity will not be
achieved until every single person
graduating is equally capable right or
ignores in the case of Celt in the case
of just like the example that we know so
well evergreen in the case of evergreen
which is when you're talking about
yep the goal that they stated was that
they needed to see equality of outcome
as well yeah at the end of a college
graduation having let people in a mere
four years earlier with extremely
unequal beginnings now are those
extremely unequal beginnings at the
point that they're 18 or 20 or whatever
they are at the point they enter college
honorable and should we you know should
we think that that's okay in a free and
liberal society no but the idea that you
can fix all of the problems that led to
people entering college with unequal
levels of degree of preparation and
educational background and sincere
Economic Security by doing something
over the course of course of four years
in college is misunderstanding God just
everything at every level well here's
the thing though obviously it's such a
preposterous logical claim that that
can't possibly be what they're saying
and so what they are saying how is it
that you could take a college of four
thousand students and guarantee that on
graduation everybody is equally capable
there is no way to take the least
prepared person and make them as capable
as the best prepared person by the time
they graduate there is no feat of magic
that could be done there's no amount of
money you could invest in the process
that would make that happen well I mean
you you could pull a Vonnegut level find
good style Harrison Bergeron that's what
you do they are inherently talking about
taking the most competent people and
hobbling you know that that's what
they're talking about because logically
it's the only way to get to the thing
that they claim that they want so at the
point that you realize we're talking
about
bobbling capable people in order that
nobody's ahead the answers okay you
obviously don't understand how the world
works you don't know what you're
inviting and we know this we see this
across I mean this this hasn't shown up
yet but I'm sure it'll be publicly
targeted soon is the whole concept of
gifted programs of educational programs
for children who show particular promise
those are already disappearing because
they are deemed unacceptably putting
resources towards those who already have
a lot and why do they have a lot they
are capable we are we are we are going
to hobble our most capable children and
imagine that we will continue to be a
dominant socio-economic force in on this
planet in 20 years no there's no way
there's no way we could be no it's
preposterous and the fact is any school
that obligates itself to this sort of
madness will subordinate its graduates
to any school that can resist any
country that signs up for this will
subordinate itself to any country that
can resist so the point is they are
inviting the destruction of whatever
works here it's not it is it is madness
and it should be addressed as such yes
okay wouldn't it be useful to generate
templates for postmodern BS free EDI
statements that's going to be equity
diversity inclusion statements I think
okay let me start again
wouldn't it be useful to generate
templates for postmodern BS free equity
diversity and inclusion statements like
new open source software licenses that
are still clearly condemning unfair
discrimination yes absolutely in the one
thing that springs to mind is our friend
the amazing Chloe Valerie with her
theory of Enchantment she's building a
curriculum to encourage basically love
and compassion over divisive nests and
and hatred but she also I think that
this is okay to say when when she came
and was on the podcast and stayed with
us she was in Portland not to come on
darkhorse podcast last fall but because
she'd been invited to give an equity
inclusion workshop for the some part of
the FAA the Federal Aviation
Administration that was having its
annual conference in at PDX
and International Airport and this is
part of what she dies this as part of
her theory of Enchantment that she does
she is a you know she's a beautiful
young youngish black woman who who has
that as one of the things that she does
and when she first told me that she was
doing this before she came and we'd met
her earlier in the summer at the
heterodox Academy conference actually
and we'd been in a lot of contact online
when she told me I've been invited to do
this oh my god Chloe you're you're you
are a Trojan horse in a good way because
you're going to deliver the actual
messaging of love and compassion actual
inclusion and the value of actual
diversity the actual value of actual
diversity in a way that people will love
to hear because of course the message is
resounding for all but the tiny fringe
of racists right and and then I'm in
asked her and I think she at that point
didn't know the answer I don't think she
does to this day actually are they going
to be shocked when you show up and
deliver an actually inclusive message or
do the people who hired you know what
you are and are they actually trying to
subvert the postmodern BS paradigm that
has taken over and I don't I don't know
which it was but it kind of doesn't
matter because she reported it always
had to be the latter
maybe I don't I don't think it matters
because you know she came and she did
her two-day workshop and she reported
such you know such community tears of
joy and of and of sadness but you know
just this glorious coming together to
left people feeling enriched and
uplifted and hopeful and that's what can
be done so I don't know of any other
example but yes it can be done well okay
I don't know of any other examples like
that one yeah but the basic idea here
this is I mean we have been learning
this trick all along right since May of
2017 and before and the question is can
you figure out how to phrase what you
actually believe explain why you
actually believe it without succumbing
to the stigma that is used to cancel
people and the very fact that we are
here tells you that this has work
so far all right being able to outline
why you believe what you believe is a
learned art and in this culture where
people are gunning for you especially if
you're in a position to reveal why
they're being absurd foolish and
dangerous it is an important one so
anyway you're right yes those statements
would be great I would suggest
practicing this and discovering what
works and what fails and why and what we
need really is everybody to bootstrap
the part of a response that they are in
a good position to deliver and those
statements would be a very good
contribution yes they would okay I'm
gonna read three more from here and
we'll get back to them if there aren't a
ton of questions and the other live
chats
I'm also I've also pulled aside excuse
me there are a few questions directly
speaking to the podcast that you put up
with URI digan beggin beggin I never get
it right yeah
so we're just gonna put those aside for
you're gonna do a live stream Q&A with
him at some point soon so I'll make sure
you'll get those to answer those later
do you have thoughts on the similarities
between Instagram black squares forced
public privileged apologies washing feet
etc and the two minutes of hate slash
Winston believing two plus two equals
five while still smelling rats at the
end of 1984 and I think I think this was
asked pretty early in the first live
stream and yeah I I don't think we are
living exactly in a 1984 world I think
it's more brave new world but there are
obviously remarkable similarities
especially in terms of the tactics I
think Orwell got the tactics exactly
right without getting the resulting
world described quite as accurately as
what um Huxley didn't it's a chimera I
would say yeah and I would also say the
important thing especially with respect
to or well is that Orwell wrote
extensively not in narrative form and to
the extent that nineteen eighty-four
resonates and that we find passages in
it absolutely shocking because of their
match for what we are living through the
point is it reflects well on his model
of how things function and he gave us a
pretty good indicator of what he thought
so
unless you know just the obviously it's
a plug for narrative right that the vast
majority of us wouldn't know who or
Allah was if he only did his scholarly
nonfiction analysis yeah but you know
and then the same with Huxley
I think Huxley also did some analysis
that wasn't fiction but certainly Orwell
did next question if one were to learn
one of the hard sciences at a PhD level
outside of institutions one is this
possible to if so how hmm readily
possible readily possible especially in
this era
now you can HD level he asks well it
depends what you mean I would say most
PhDs are not very interesting
contributions and so you know in terms I
would say the the methods though of many
of the sciences require and this is this
is because of the way the socio-economic
model of big science in universities has
gone not because of anything intrinsic
to science but most PhD level science
over in the skin and biology and
chemistry realms require labs with a lot
of money so that's gonna that's gonna be
very hard to to source on your own
there's a lot of sort of the you know
evolutionary theory and over in math
space and potentially in physics space
that you can potentially do well without
the labs suffice it to say there are
things you cannot do because the
technology cannot be sourced
individually that is certainly do I mean
if you're a physicist whose work
requires a Collider you need access to
the collider right right but there are
many PhDs where you could figure out how
to do the work I don't know that it
would be worth you know there's a lot of
time wasted in a PhD process and you
could do better and I think actually
Yuri dagan is a great demonstration he
doesn't have a PhD but he has a very
deep understanding of how the highly
technical biological realm that
intersects his business life works yeah
and so look autodidact are wonderful the
tools that are available to you between
you know people on youtube we're willing
to teach you to do just about anything
you would want to do at a technical
level
and all of the source material that
would tell you how to process think
about the the resulting data yes of
course it's possible but there's a lot
about PhDs that is a waste of your time
and so you could probably do the
equivalent in terms of getting to the
value in three years if you didn't have
to please a committee that had other
obligations and things like them okay do
you think that today is overly
nihilistic pop culture which deifies the
bad guys as in Game of Thrones Joker
Rick and Morty Bojack horseman is
reflective of some of the postmodern
Theory's surfacing today as in the 16:19
project so let me just parse that a
little bit the 16:19 project being this
ascendant attempt by the New York Times
to describe the history of the United
States entirely through the lens of
everything was built on on the on the
labor on the enslaved labor of black
people
the 16:19 project has I think earned a
Pulitzer at this point it is right it is
it has been adopted in several school
curricula for I believe starting next
year and it has been widely widely
discredited by many historians across
many demographic markers including at
least political ideology and race so
there are there are many reasons to
think that this is in fact a postmodern
take on the history of race in America
which obviously in here you know Eric's
words ring in my ear do we need to say
that slavery existed and that it was bad
I don't think we do
but the 16:19 project is obviously at
one level an attempt to describe that
but it does not appear to be a
good-faith attempt any more than a
hashtag black lives matter appears to be
good faith and yet it is ascendant to
justice hash
black lives matters so the question then
is the deification of bad guys in
today's Neil istic pop culture does that
contribute to the ascendancy of pomo
Bowl like the 16:19 project you know
it's a it's a fair question but I don't
think that that's it's far from a
description purely of what's taking
place in pop culture in other words even
in places where there's a lot of glory
shown amongst the bad guys
it's very frequently the bad guys with
honour that are the most interesting
characters you and I have a a long
relationship with the character Omar
little on the wire who was a bad guy he
was a gun-toting robber but he robbed
drug dealers and anyway he was a very
interesting complex character so I do
things gotta have a good man gots to
have a go gotta go
so the thing is really we're watching
we're rewatching right now with our boys
the extraordinary series peaky blinders
which yeah they're they're mobsters at
some level I mean that's nice but boy
are they complex and rich and I think
really I don't know I haven't seen all
of the things on the list here I do
think that we have a problem maybe I
would point than to the particular
pop-culture references made here rather
to the deification of superhero culture
that soup that that through Marvel
Comics places the pure good against the
pure evil I think I'm less familiar with
what's going on in that space but I
think that that that is a big part of
what has entered especially kids minds
growing up into a world in which they
actually think that if evil always looks
like that they'll know it when they see
it and oh if I've got a label that says
I'm anti that I'm anti fascist or
whatever it is well then I must be on
the good side yeah I think that's deep I
think that there's something about the
cartoon efficacious involved in
superheroes
that does result in a tendency to take
that in which there is grey and shove it
one side or the other I think that's
important
hey Zach you want to show us box again
thank you that resonates for me yeah
let's keep track of that idea
yeah no it's it's something I've written
about a little bit and I think actually
the there's a there's another piece of
it which is something we've also talked
about before which is the Disneyfication
so quite different from the sort of you
know I think especially boys but
increasingly everyone grow up on these
these sort of superhero supervillain
narratives but then the you know the
Disney narratives tend to be very very
simplistic in a way that appeals
especially to girls but increasingly to
everyone as well and both of these just
inform developing minds with these with
these narratives that are fictitious in
the wrong way right like fiction is
powerful because it tells us something
real and deep about ourselves and it
allows us access to those truths that
maybe a dispassionate analytical
analysis would not just exactly in the
same way that we know in nineteen
eighty-four and none of us knows the
name of an essay that Orwell wrote about
the same stuff right but it requires
that the fiction is deep and that it's
complex and the characters are plausibly
real and the situation's could happen
and you know even I say this as a huge
fan of and writer of science fiction
that even that stuff which is which is
speculative
you know specfic speculative fiction the
best of it is not does not have
one-dimensional societies or systems or
characters and yet so much of literally
the cartoon universe yeah the superhero
universe the Disney universe has
incredibly simple narratives that leave
people with a sense of of utopia being
possible and it's not so I suspect we're
gonna get a lot of pushback on this
point because there are a lot of people
who are deeply involved in these
universes and I do think that there is
something important taking place there
but really the question is is there
something is there a dimension removed
in order for these stories to be
extraordinary and the way they are and
is that thing have
developmental impact on people and I do
wonder I know Martin Scorsese got in
trouble for saying effectively that he
didn't consider these things cinema I
didn't say that no at all and I didn't I
didn't say they're not well I don't
think what he said was terrible I yeah I
didn't I didn't even I didn't go that
far Yeah right I am saying I think there
is a simplicity of character and world
of development that if it is a majority
of what you were being exposed to as a
child especially if you are also being
drugged and helicopter parented and kept
from all risk of course you end up
coming of age supposedly an adult deeply
confused about the nature of what's
possible and you may really actually
think that abolishing the police is a
plausible answer to the problems of
society you may actually I agree yeah ok
we're gonna skip to questions from the
next one and then the next one and the
next one let's say you've said sorry
we're not going to get to all these
again
I didn't hear discuss Marxism in the
Dark Horse talk Bret do you believe or
not believe that Marxist philosophy is
driving any of this oh this clearly has
a relationship to Marxism it's not
exactly a version of Marxism we've seen
the association with it is you know if
you're painting with a broad brush it
just does and frankly there's a lot of
Marxism in academia and it's sort of
academic Marxism you know in the sense
that you know there's there's important
stuff in Marx's critique of capitalism
it's just not it's not like everything
mark said was wrong but the conflation
of the critique with the prescription
the prescription is wrong we know why
the prescription is wrong right and the
fact that a prescription that looks like
that and is even looks to be an
extension of it
is unfolding in the streets that the
demands appear not only to be tactically
Marxist but they also appear to be
thematically Marxist the direction they
push is clearly a Marxist
solution or some Marxist non solution
it's an empty set because it's so
utopian that even you know even somebody
who believed in 20th century Marxism
would know that this was not going to
work so anyway yeah it has a lot to do
with Marxism and I don't think we need
to focus too much on that I think
frankly maoism is a better match that
maoism is obviously a flavour of Marxism
but the Maoism whether or not to Mao ISM
is great enough that that's where we
ought to look for our best historical
parallel ok is there any evolutionary
aspect intuition or a product of skill
based behavior which it's that's not a
counterpoint right right so here's the
thing there's good intuition which is
well tutored and there's naive intuition
which is not well tutored intuition is
the product of parts of your mind that
you don't have direct conscious access
to which give you a conclusion that is
either based on lots of experience or
not so you know there's a phrase in
Aeronautics if it doesn't look right it
won't fly right ok so like for example
the the stealth fighter
nicknamed the hobbling goblin right it's
a very ugly plane and it doesn't fly
very well it does avoid radar right but
but the basic point is look your
intuition about what a flying aircraft
looks like is tutored by the fact that
you've seen lots of flying aircraft and
people who know flying aircraft well
they know what a dihedral is and these
sorts of things they have an even better
tutored intuition and so they can look
at a plane and kind of tell whether it's
a plausible design there's limits to it
there's stuff that you can do you know
whatever it is out there in Mojave
though something rather composites you
know these are planes that don't look
like historical planes that prove that
these things are possible but
nonetheless intuition is tutored by
experience those who have a ton of
experience in a realm will have high
quality intuition and it's there's
nothing mystical about this it's just
simply the nature of your mind being
only partially conscious
yeah you've said previously that Trump
is the wrong leader for the situation
what type of leader do we need and is it
better to have Trump than an ultra woke
leader that last parts of tricky one
yeah anacs like you know it's really
tricky we did we as much as Biden as a
decrepit clown and I won't vote for him
one thing we did see was the ultra woke
on the incredibly numerous slate of
democratic Democrats who were running
did get thrown off relatively quickly
although what we did see was candidates
who know someone like Elizabeth Warren
who I had liked very very much became
more and more woke and thus lost more
and more votes and became less and less
of a viable candidate so I I'm not I I
don't think we're there on the other
hand what the Democrats did arrived at
is untenable as well so I don't boy I
don't enema I have to say he did one
thing right Biden Biden mmm-hmm yeah he
said he wasn't gonna do fund the police
okay so so brave that's a really low bar
to get that one right but at least he
got it right there's that you did it
through a spokesman so what the hell Joe
come on dude so in any case what I would
say is what's the right candidate for
the moment a courageous capable Patriot
period any courageous capable Patriot
will do it's good enough a president
doesn't need to be encyclopedic ly
knowledgeable about everything a
president needs to be able to delegate
the job of figuring out what's going on
and what might be done about it to other
people they need to be able to
synthesize this and they need to have
our values at heart and to understand
how to implement right to figure out how
to delegate who to delegate to they need
to be able to recognize insight and
insight across domains that they might
themselves may not have insight into and
what you proposed at the end of the
livestream number 19 is exactly this and
you know you proposed
McRaven and yang as a dual ticket where
it doesn't matter who's on top they flip
and they're you know they're are are
people not only they flip they they
govern as a team unless there is some
difference they cannot resolve where
something needs to be a call needs to be
made that's doesn't allow for dialogue
but anyway yes smart capable patriot
period I don't care we're on the
political spectrum there if they match
that description and we get a chance to
vote for him that's the way to go the
phrase right side of history annoys me
that means well nothing if you care
about principles how history remembers
he was irrelevant otherwise everyone
just lines up with whoever they think
will win [ __ ] sorry I hate to break
it to you but the fact is look I guess
I'm Jewish I get to use Nazis as an
example the fact is the whole point of
that phrase is not that my side is the
right side of history it's that there is
a side that will be understood in
retrospect to have been the right side
of history and that this is not based on
who won okay the Nazis would have been
the wrong side of history irrespective
of who one man in the high castle is a
very interesting narrative I suggest it
it takes the other path through that
moment of history and see how things
look but nonetheless the fact that you
can look back on the Nazi era and say I
know who I want to have been right I
want to have been this person I'm in
danger being that person so how do I
restructure so I'm no longer in danger
of being that person and only this
person is a possibility that's the
question and frankly I have seen the
term right side of history abused into
uselessness that's the problem it's not
that it isn't useful it's very useful
but it's also fragile and it cannot
withstand people abusing it so I think
that's what you're detecting it's the
abuse of it not the useful utility of
the concept itself so please let's
rehabilitate it or at least give it a
break it's not absurd on its face it's
absurd in the way people use it
are you familiar with media accounts
from the Ukraine and elsewhere that
claim Russian troll farms are working on
social media to inflame the protesters
legitimate journalism or anti Russian
propaganda I don't I haven't heard these
media accounts
the final question legitimate journalism
or anti Russian propaganda always a good
question
copy both I don't even know hoodie both
I mean here's what we do know we know
that there are sock puppets all over
social media my guess is they're hired
routinely by many many different
entities that have the resources to hire
them in shape opinion about everything
from whether you like this mac and
cheese more than that to whether or not
you think these people our heroes or
runaway Maoists or whatever so so you
being cryptically doing the work the
marketing work for like Nike you know to
figure out if putting a black lives
matter fist up in their advertising is
going to incite site people to buy shoes
and site is the wrong word there but
maybe not every manner of manipulation
is happening we know that the Navy had a
program for sock puppets I just was
years ago but they had a software to
manage them and all this stuff so look
there's sock puppets all over the damn
thing there are false followers that
people can buy themselves in order to
make themselves look more important than
they are there's all kinds of garbage
and worst one of all in my opinion far
more dangerous than sock puppets and
phony followers and stuff like that are
the algorithms themselves these these
are corporations they have fiduciary
responsibilities to their shareholders
they have little Maoist battles going on
inside of their corporate headquarters
their algorithms are going to reflect
all of these tensions we can't see the
algorithms we don't know what effect
they are having on our ability to talk
to each other they don't we don't know
what effect they are having on our
ability to think collectively about what
we're supposed to do next if this is
this is us collectively going mad that's
it we are in huge danger because we are
collectively going mad as a result of
something that we know where it is but
we don't know what it is
what it wants and what effect it's
having on our suspicions of other people
and all that stuff so you know it's not
like Tristan Harris didn't try to warn
us he tried to warn us um but I will
also remind us of what the Department of
Homeland Security officer whom you spoke
with a few days ago said which is that
his sense and this is just yeah this is
one guy's sense but who's who's working
sort of the front lines of the street
battles in the u.s. right now that
something is trying to divide us
something is just many things are trying
to divide us they're they're jockeying
for position yeah he said he thought we
were being played didn't know by what
but he felt strongly we were being
played look I mean when we've got you
know the cult of q and on also mm-hmm I
knew I didn't trust you when he wasn't
followed by a you like what the hell is
that
cutter well exactly yeah I guess the
contractor no big enemies now we've
finally gone and done it yeah yeah we've
gotten the key what you playing everyone
is going to agree on is that we're first
against the wall right they're all gonna
just that's good that's what's gonna
bring them together okay we've got a
couple of questions almost an hour
okay I wanna we're gonna try to get
through a few more of these we've got a
few questions from a candidate for
governor in Washington who's interested
in defining the police and not for an
income tax who's trying to make a
positive difference is trying to reach
out it's we get a lot of people trying
to reach out appreciate that it sounds
like you may be trying to make a
positive difference though you've
mentioned that the BLM group isn't
trustworthy could you expand on that
it's hard to figure out for me what
comes from BLM proper and what doesn't
that is exactly where it is shut down
stem actually come from for instance
yeah a lot of the stuff is gonna be
cryptic and some of it can be sorted out
some of its hiding in plain sight I
don't I don't know how close the
relationship is between BLM and shut
down stem what I can say is the
consistency of those two messages
marching together through time is so
great that it doesn't matter the point
is it's one movement it has objectives
right shut down stem as a side
project of the thing that is rioting in
the streets and the riots in the streets
are a side project of something that
wants power in all sorts of institutions
and it has its plans and basically
everything it's advocating everything
it's advocating is a suspension of the
rules that usually allow something
useful to emerge those rules aren't
perfect there's lots of noise right not
enough signal but what they want is a
suspension of the rules where do they
want a suspension of the rules well
let's get rid of the police we'll
suspend the rules they will suspend the
rule of law will suspend Occam's razor
we're gonna suspend every rule that we
usually find frustrating and that's
gonna put us in charge so we can't
listen to that voice that wants to
suspend all the rules that that way lies
madness that way is warlordism pure and
simple yeah okay
I've lost where I am again because my
trackpad isn't working how how would you
respond to the claim that it is not the
scientific method that is flawed but
rather that people of color are
systematically denied access to stem I
would say that in the past people of
color were system Athleta night access
to stem just like women weren't just you
know like like as we have already said
like a lot of people were poor people
were people people without rich families
were women were people of color all of
this but I don't see any evidence that
this is true now in fact I see quite the
opposite now is the quite the opposite a
fairly new phenomenon maybe but does
what is going on in stem look open and
inclusive and welcoming even though the
numbers of people aren't a match for the
ratios of those demographics in the
general population yeah it looks really
actually inviting and inclusive in part
because what stem is is searching for
what is actually true in the universe
and why on earth in a modern liberal
world would you hobble yourself by not
including some people in the equation
you pick you pick the best regardless of
what else is true of them well it even
goes beyond that because
these Sciences housed inside
universities universities are for better
or worse liberal institutions people
like it when somebody who is from a
demographic that is understood to be
oppressed shows up in the room because
it relieves them and you know even just
cynically it relieves them of the
accusation that they are displaying
racism so it's welcoming right now in my
opinion there are things that prevent
blacks for example from showing up at
the upper echelon of the sciences but
those things have a lot to do with
deeper more complex problems so for
example what effect is led in your water
have on the likelihood that you're gonna
end up in a math department well I don't
know but there are places with led in
the water and you're much more likely to
have led in your water if you're black I
also go what about the fact that taxes
are collected locally and therefore
schools and poor neighbourhoods suck
more than schools in rich neighborhoods
what effect does that have on math
preparedness and what effect does math
preparedness have on whether people show
up in biology chemistry mathematics
physics a lot so so those could be read
as systemic denial of access to stem
without it being at all at the level of
the universities or what is going on
within the disciplines of stem right but
if it's a societal level inequality
society I would say it's just even an
echo of past discrimination that
separated us into neighborhoods that
have different amounts of resource to
spend on things like schooling and clean
water all right got another one yeah
which is that I had this is years ago so
when we were in graduate school at
Michigan and we were both teeing
basically you know intro bio and more
advanced bio and most of our students
there were pre-med because at a big you
know an r1 university like University of
Michigan most of the biology majors are
pre-med or pre-dental and I had a number
of black students and in one of the
classes I I had you know enough that
they and they were they all came into
the class friends with each other and it
happened to be all black men well make
four or five
in a class of 25 or so and I was it was
some lab I was overhearing them talk
about their plans and they were all
going to med school and none of them
were looking to go into science which is
to say you know that the STEM fields
medicine isn't included in stem often
because it's seen you know stem is the
pursuit of science for Sciences sake or
engineering technology whereas medicine
is this implied thing and ended up in a
conversation with these young men and
again this is you know 25 years ago at
this point but when I asked them you
know why are none of you interested in
going into science because at least
three of them as I remember had had you
know great facility in scientific
thinking which is different from being
able to be a good doctor those aren't
completely overlapping things what they
to a person said and so of course is not
going to be true of all young black men
but what they to a person said was I'm
the first person in my family to have
this opportunity to go to college there
is no way that I am going to pass up the
opportunity to you know pay off the debt
that I'm incurring by going to college
and not be able to make enough money for
myself and for my parents and for my
future family
the fact is medicine pay at that point
now it's not so true but you know in the
in the mid-90s medicine pays science
doesn't it's not nearly as from Unity
remunerative and it doesn't guarantee
you a position from which you can be
financially secure and for people who
were more likely to be coming from
socio-economic disparities such that no
one in their families had ever been
financially secure they were making
choices to go into medicine rather than
science precisely because of past
disparities and there were choices in
this case they were completely choices
it wasn't they're being forced away from
science into medicine but they were
choosing to go into medicine because it
looked like the better financial bet
yeah it makes total sense so you've got
lots of forces that might result in
unequal numbers showing up in these
various disciplines
what is conspicuous is that this
movement
the best tool the only tool to figuring
out what's really going on and to what
extent these patterns are resulting in
that ultimate pattern of differential
representation in these places the tools
are scientific any movement that is
pushing the unhooking of the scientific
tools doesn't want you to know what's
really going on it's not pushing some
Afrocentric alternative to Western
science it is trying to blind people by
removing the tool that would allow them
to know what's actually going on any
movement that wants to blind you is a
cult it doesn't want you talking to your
friends it doesn't want you talking to
your family right those people are not
to be trusted science is not to be
trusted that is an attempt to gain power
by unhooking the things that might
challenge it science included let's do
two more from this one and see what's
what showed up in the last livestream
all right okay what would you suggest to
invite people into this conversation who
might otherwise be right for it but have
an aversion largely because of things
like the stigma against Jordan Peterson
well I don't think we can do it on this
Q&A but I do think the most important
question the thing that was very hard to
get anyone to pay attention to at the
Evergreen meltdown was that there is an
alternative story there's a story that
treats the question of why the
differential representation happens with
full nuance what is it that happened to
black America and why right I think that
story is it's horrifying in some sense
but it's hopeful because it isn't the
thing that people fear so in some sense
we are drowning out a much better more
interesting more tractable problem with
fairy tales and the question is can we
now talk about that alternative can we
put the BLM version of events up against
a scientifically robust competitor right
can we put them head-to-head rather than
allow one to shut down the other so I
think we need to have that conversation
yeah we do I mean I think I'm waiting
for the new fiction
that actually does this right you know
me you mean the new fiction like the new
narrator new good compelling deep and
rich narrative fiction this is we don't
have time
slightly no people can write fast good
good people can write fast I think that
we've got some excellent documentary
filmmakers doing some of this work right
now which is compelling you know that
they will often I mean like Mike Nina's
the three piece three-part documentary
really mixes the analysis in with the
story and that is part of what is
compelling about it to people but I'm
just I'm thinking of another another
this is not this is like what's wrong
rather than what can we do going forward
but I'm reminded of a moment boy six
months ago or so when Zach and I went to
Powell's
this amazing independent gigantic
bookstore in downtown Portland and we
were looking for books young adult books
that Toby our younger son who's 14 now
might be interested in and we must have
wandered the why a the young adult Isles
for 20 minutes and literally could not
find a book written in the last 15 years
that I was willing to take home actually
that's not sure I took one hi was I
thought one was wonderful and I took it
home and I thought I'd read it first
and I got about 50 pages in and it
turned super woke and intolerant and it
was you know it's a it's like a space
opera that went into some crazy space
and this is what the entire young adult
fiction book shelves look like now you
know you end up having to go back into
you know I picked up se Hinton yeah the
outsiders and you know some other good
stuff that you know it tells real
stories about real characters with real
trouble and we we could I think have
some good fiction quickly here but I
don't think it'll work I mean I think
the stories need to happen you and I are
in complete agreement that what changes
minds is the narrative version not be
the academic version mm-hmm but the
problem is this is why people burn books
and it's all too easy with the kind of
power I mean look if they're getting
science and nature and the Triple A s
and Caltech two broadcasts fail t to
their anti science agenda then what they
will do to any narrative that reveals
them is they will make it immoral to
engage it and the people who will engage
it in that context are people who don't
need it they may enjoy it it may enhance
their understanding but the peoples is
one of the powerful things about fiction
as it sneaks in again I think we're just
you know if this dies down if something
happens that turns this around and we
get another two years you might be able
to get that fiction lodged someplace
that would do the job but hey I don't I
mean I see the force that turns around
we need we need someone who can see this
high up enough at some someplace like
Disney all right some someone who could
actually make non woke anti woke but but
difficult and honest narrative that is
also compelling I mean again you're
talking about every institution has this
battle going on within it if that's
Twitter and that's Facebook and that's
Instagram
then how exactly does the thing go viral
if the algorithm decides it doesn't like
it well so I we haven't we didn't we
haven't actually seen Joker yet so I
can't really speak to it but you know I
saw a lot of the lead-up to it and how
enraged people were that it was being
made and the fact is that it was it was
a big hit in part because some people
anyway are now seeing the outrage as an
indicator that that's actually some a
door I want to go through okay so maybe
maybe encouraging that is like a look
look look to the outraged mob and see
what they're telling you that you
shouldn't look at and look there well
that's a good guide yeah look at what
they don't want you to look at that's
for sure
it doesn't catch on to the to the you
know the masses
but I actually want to take back my
pessimism because I now in light of what
you've said I now know the path okay
what path is that the fiction has to be
subversive sure right it has to be the
antidote it has to be the inverse of the
Trojan horse as you were describing
Chloe Val during yeah and the point is
the fiction that the enemy doesn't spot
as subversive of their message but that
will cause what we used to say the dime
to drop for people that fiction has a
tremendous amount of power and so the
question is do we have a do we have
writers who are clever enough not just
to write the fiction well that we need
but to write it in a form that it
doesn't get spotted yeah well I mean and
we've we've had it recently you know it
like this is what the matrix was at some
level
well the matrix was the allegory of the
cave you know but a lot more people than
Plato do it does yeah oh yeah true um
and it reached them now rather than 2500
years ago or whenever whenever Plato was
probably off by several hundred years
but thank you Leighton um yeah like but
nonetheless there is something to be
done
you're right that people do things I
mean you know part of the problem with
the movie thing is that the thing that
writes movies and then deploys them is a
hybrid of some sort of market force and
some sort of artistic force yeah and in
order to do what you're talking about
you really can't afford it to be market
driven it has to be driven by by an or
well-liked figure yeah okay one more
here over the last several decades
academia and science have become bad at
challenging power structures and self
defense can resistance to irrational
authority be introduced as part of
standard scientific training if so how
this is exactly what we were doing oh
yeah this is exactly what we were doing
and it it got it it has to be like this
is the scientific method the way that
you do science is is inherently about
rejecting irrational authority about
what
acting any appeal to Authority if it's
made simply on the basis of this person
in a lab code made it yeah so in effect
what this person is saying and I think
they're right on the money is that
science has become co-opted it has been
co-opted by market forces which is true
those market forces have deviated it
from the thing that makes it most potent
which is that in science if you are
right then you win right you win by
virtue of having more productive
predictive power than the alternatives
and so that thing is the perfect
location for people with problems with
authority now Heather's right we were
doing this at Evergreen it was only
really possible at Evergreen because
evergreen because it was founded by
subversives gave faculty freedom to do
what they thought needed to be done
without any administrator being able to
tell you you can't teach that way or you
have to teach this subject so it was
open to that and almost no place is and
evergreen isn't now anymore either
so in some sense yeah scientists needs
to be part of the scientific education
it's a weird thing because it's hard to
teach people how to resist Authority
this is why other and I talked so much
about the necessity that anybody who is
gonna do high quality thinking have a
relationship with some realm where
whether you succeeded or failed is not
there is not decided by an authority
it's decided by whether your tower
stands up or your motor turns over or
some things there's a kiln intact or
your bicycle runs or your table is flat
all these things you got to have a
relationship with one of those realms
because then it will tell you when the
authority in front of you isn't making
any sense that will tell you actually
you should trust you should trust what
you know rather than oh if the authority
so so then it's true yeah okay so I
think we're gonna try to answer just a
couple more here there's a question here
about the extinction of the Irish elk I
think we're gonna save that since we're
not mostly doing that kind of question
right now turns out so for those who are
excited for us to come back to that is
that
incredibly antlered beast yep so there
are a few here asking how can I explain
what's going on succinctly how you know
what can I say to my friends you know
what's what's the sound bite and I want
to just put that out there I think
that's one one will answer laughs but I
want you to look Brett at this one that
I've got highlighted and should I read
that aloud and should we answer it
before I tell you guys what that is to
do yeah I think this is a this is one
that should be discussed okay so this is
the terrific love you both Eric as well
are you armed if not I'd like to donate
a firearm legally of course shipped to
your nearest gun shop stay safe we are
armed and I I don't like that we feel
like we have to be that that feels like
a major loss already but a I think
there's something that needs to be said
which is at the moment we've got we've
got a violent mob in the streets
demonstrating how much power it has so
far my understanding is it has pretty
well stayed out of people's
neighborhoods I believe it is stayed out
of people's neighborhoods because of the
Second Amendment and this is not what
the Second Amendment was written for
it's not really about personal
protection it's a hedge against tyranny
but I think the gun control debate now
has to include the observation that the
rational fear that people who would like
the law suspended will have of entering
people's neighborhoods is it may very
well be what is preventing people from
engaging in the violent up ending of
people at home or their neighborhoods so
in any case what I would say is yeah we
we are armed I think I gave a
a glib response somebody weaker to back
asked if it was a good time to buy guns
and I said no because the lines the gun
stars are too long they have it because
the supply is too low and the demand is
too high but the demand is really high
for a reason because the people are
rightly frightened they're watching well
this was before before the last two
weeks this is at the point that lock
downs were beginning to hurry out and
and people were legitimately questioned
whether or not supply chains would
remain intact
and what what potentially months of lock
downs would do to people's psychologies
yeah and that's part of what we're
seeing right now where we're seeing it
just exactly what we feared and it
hasn't you know can easily get far worse
so anyway I would say if you are in the
position we were in and you're thinking
should I or shouldn't I I would say
unfortunately given that we don't know
how this plays out and we can see what
it's doing and how quickly it is growing
and demonstrating its power I would be
hard-pressed to tell you not to buy some
weapons I would also say I know how to
use them you absolutely want to know how
to use them and you want to know how to
store them and so you know gun safe is
the way to go all right final question
for tonight today whatever it is I don't
know how long we've been here yeah so I
asked one version of it but it's it's
this one I'm struggling to explain to
well-meaning friends what is really
going on here with these protests on BLM
they are fully bought into the guilt and
shaming narrative what can I tell them
and someone else I think it was someone
else me was the same person asked you
know what
what's a succinct description of this
and you know this this the answer could
then feed into and like who do you who
do you point people to like you know I
get especially given that the mainstream
media did a really solid job of
convincing a whole swath of the public
that Jordan Peterson for instance was
some kind of outright loon well which
he's obviously not so well I was just
gonna say this is this was my point
earlier about the people who have
predicted what happened the stuff that
caught other people off-guard but has
been predicted by some
some who predicted it you ought to
listen to them you ought to figure out
how they did that trick right Jordan
Peterson predicted that people were
going to be compelled by courts to use
certain language and that the threat of
losing your freedom was going to be
invoked right he was right about that so
if you've been told that Jordan Peterson
is an all right gateway drug or
something like that you had it wrong
somebody lied to you and now you can go
back and fix it you can go see what he
said
likewise for us you might have been told
we were racists who you know weren't
interested in seeing oppression of black
people and or something like that
well you relied to now you know we
predicted a lot about what and what is
unfolding in our streets right now so
you can go back to those things and if
you follow the people who've gotten it
right you'll find they're connected to
other people who got it right and you
can sort of bootstrap your way there in
terms of what you say to your friends
who are thoroughly ensconced in the
stuff and I'm not promising promising
you it's gonna work because as we've
said elsewhere and here many times these
crises reveal character your friends may
have a character defect that is going to
cause them to become pawns of this
movement and if they can't be awakened
from that zombie state then it's
probably the moment that you need to go
find better friends but if you want to
try to see if you can wake them up the
answer is look if you capitulate to this
if you start broadcasting it you are
actually adding firepower that will be
used against other good people right
they're gonna come for the next people
if you are surrendering to this in order
to solve your own problem you are making
a worse problem for other people and
that's not your right and if you say
that to people and they stare you down
walk away but they don't that's I don't
think this is responsive because people
don't know that that's what they're
doing well then you have to make it
clear well but that's that's what the
question is how is what do you say how
is it that you make it clear that this
is not what it seems and that by
by bending over backwards to you know to
acquiesce to this movement you're
actually making a problem for their
people if the people who are bending
over backwards actually believe that
this is about anti racism and this is
actually about ending systemic
oppression that sounds like a racist
position yeah but so how what is what is
the initial thing like I've got the only
thing I've come up with an answer to
this so far is both you and I you know
why all I've got to work on the book
I've done fewer short pieces but you
know but both you and I have you know
active Twitter feeds that put things out
there that act as ways for people to get
into this I've got the names of a few
other people who you you could and
should follow who often have good pieces
so I'm looking at Zack you can put just
briefly up there's a Guardian article of
all places you know the Guardian is
pretty woke but Thomas charity and
Williams who I read pieces from his
essay about play about can lose the
plague a few episodes ago has written
yet another amazing piece and this isn't
exactly about about you know the
hypocrisy of BLM but it is it is like
that Chloe Valerie John Wood jr. just
wrote an essay that I posted on Twitter
I don't think it's coincidence but it
shouldn't matter and yet it does in the
current moment that all three of those
guys are black well through those people
are black but I follow Jim Lindsey as
well he's often got the incisive thing
but I don't know the right way in I
don't understand why you're pushing back
on what I said because this is exactly
what we did
we watched our College turned upside
down and we said to people out loud we
said to them this thing is not what it
pretends to be it is co-opting but is
that that's the piece I didn't hear what
you said before you have to start with
this isn't what it seems but then how do
you demonstrate that it's not what it
seems the thing you don't they're not up
to it but no but that's that's then it's
hopeless
no it's not hopeless it's not hopeless
the fact is what percentage of our
colleagues woke up very few very few was
it incumbent on us to invest twice three
times what we did invest in order to
wake them up and what do you think would
have happened if we did okay but here's
how about this
almost none if not actually none of our
students succumbed to this this actual
mind virus mm-hmm right and not just
those students we had then but but past
students as well as far as far as we
know right so it is possible to educate
people in clear thinking in first
principles thinking in not responding to
appeals to Authority or appeals to
emotion or appeals to things that are
wrapped up shiny and look nice but
actually have something really toxic
inside it is it is possible but I don't
know I don't know how to do it in short
term I know how to do it if I've got 10
weeks and I get to spend two weeks in
the field with me right but can I
actually do but I don't know how to do
it if I've got two minutes or five
minutes or I'm sitting over drinks with
people for an evening even I'm not sure
you can't and the fact is what we did in
the classroom did this job because it
was honorable and complete not because
it's the job we were trying to do so to
the extent that our students broke in
the right direction and it wasn't all of
them there are some students who flirted
with this thing sure but none of them
came after us for one thing there was
nothing to come after us about right
right so although the other side would
have been empowered if any of our firm
against I would have loved it but the
war that would have broken out by
between the people who were telling it
like it was and the people who were
pretending it was otherwise would not
have worked out well for them so it
didn't happen
yeah but nonetheless the unfortunate
lesson and everybody is looking for an
escape hat from this most of your
friends probably are not up to this
moment in history they're going to break
the wrong way and unfortunately this
moment is so serious that that actually
I think ought to guide your investment I
think we could have invested three times
what we invested and not woke a single
other person up to what they were doing
at Evergreen I don't think they were
going to be awakened they were they were
pre-programmed to surrender to this
thing as our most people so this is just
this is just fascinating to me because I
think had we been having this discussion
20 years ago clearly you and I would
have been on the opposite sides
of this of this question that at the
point that you and I met in high school
and through much of college and graduate
school I was an unrepentant misanthrope
I thought very little of the average
human I much preferred the the with the
companionship of non-human friends and
while there are several humans whom I
adore and love deeply three of whom I am
lucky enough to live with I really
didn't have much hope for most people I
looked out there and thought oh it's
it's just hopeless and you know I mean
I've said this to you what what cured me
and that suggests that it was a disease
that needed to be cured me that I needed
to be cured from but what kind of cured
me of my misanthropy actually was
teaching at Evergreen was meeting the
students the 25 50 75 students hundred
students depending on how many programs
there were in a year and how many people
I was teaching with who almost to a
person were only students who were open
and generous with their time and with
their thoughts and with their work and
were open to ideas that made them
uncomfortable and I pushed them and they
pushed me and I just came to thank
actually if you can do this with such
stunning success if much more than 90%
of every one of my classes I feel like
came away like okay I learned stuff I
feel I know more about the world and I'm
better able to navigate the world now
than I did before I had much more hope
for Humanity as a result of that and of
course that that sense came crashing
down around my ears when almost none of
our colleagues stood up for us when you
know only our students and a few
handfuls a few handful of staff faculty
and admin stood up for us whenever green
broke but that does leave me with the
sense that actually I do think people
are up to this I really do I think
people are up to this but I don't know
how to do it in short in short periods
of time but I mean I don't think we're
disagreeing okay if you have somebody
for three months full-time can you reach
them sure most of these people are
reachable under those circumstances
people can't reach them so I mean the I
think this
like most faculty suck at what they do
yeah and they don't give a damn about
their students either and so they don't
manage to and then they claimed they
weren't bothering to and Lucy that's
also true don't bother to reach students
and so that gives the sense it
reinforces the sense that most people
are unreachable because most people are
unreached okay but not even sure what
we're what we're disagreeing about here
because at some level I'm not arguing
that if you could rerun these people's
developmental experience that they
wouldn't be immune to this I believe
anybody could have a developmental
experience that would cause you to be
immune to this madness but given where
we are in 2020 these people have had the
experiences they have that are making
them ultra vulnerable to this can you
wake your friends well your friends are
who they are arriving at this moment
could you wake your friends if you had
you know a year with them off somewhere
where they were insulated from bad
messages over social media
sure potentially but can you wake
somebody who's you know who's who's
espousing these nonsense beliefs now as
a result of some mixture of they sound
right to them and they are afraid of
what happens if they say anything else
are those people reachable know they've
been zombified right I'm not declaring
them unrecoverable at all I'm saying can
you with your tools now reach them
probably not in most cases but the
really important question is what is the
right use of your time and your effort
all right and the right use at this
moment if you are facing this problem is
figure out who's gonna break the right
way and be it's not totally bleak right
the people who will break the right way
have strength of character they're high
quality people and so anyway I think if
you know somebody's asking us this
question what should I do
my honest advice at least for my part my
honest advice is you could figure out
who is capable of being awakened from
this awaken them and then make your
peace with what happens with the others
because
you know you could invest your you could
invest almost all of your effort in
trying to wake everybody who's not
seeing it and have very little impact
and at the moment you do need to think
about how you're going to protect
yourself in all meanings of that term
you know how are you gonna survive in a
world where every institution is being
taken over by people who say this stuff
well either you're gonna say it too and
see whether or not they'll treat you
well enough in the future world or
you're gonna stand up and say what you
know to be accurate and then you don't
know what world you're living in so I
don't know I'm not giving up on humanity
obviously but I at the present moment
we're behind the eight ball yeah all
right we're done all right I think we've
done it well folks this has been a
harrowing journey we will see you soon
please like subscribe let us know what
you think in the comments and stay safe
you